the threat of tropical storm elsa off
the coast of florida
strong winds and heavy rain are already
hammering the florida keys
ted scouten of our cbs miami station
wfor
is in key west way down there ted good
morning to you what's it like where you
are
tony the wind and rain really picked up
throughout the night and then into the
morning it's been gaining strength
ever since you can take a look out at
the ocean there normally this water is
very docile but you can see right there
uh not docile at all as the storm gets
closer we're getting
more surf coming in to the lower florida
keys now elsa gained strength after
tearing through cuba yesterday
it lashed the island with strong winds
and nearly a foot of rain flooding towns
and
forcing more than a hundred thousand
people to evacuate their homes
as elsa moves north along the florida
coast it's likely to make landfall early
tomorrow
north of tampa bay people in the storm's
path aren't taking any chances
they've been filling up sandbags and
stocking up on water
15 counties around the state of florida
are in a state of emergency
now one thing that florida officials and
emergency officials are happy about
is that most of the tourists who are
here for the fourth of july weekend are
now gone
and if people have any plans to fly out
of key west later on today
that's probably not going to happen most
of the flights have been cancelled
gail all right thank you very much we're
down there in key west
way down there tip of florida all right
thank you ted
he's from our cbs station wfor
reporting for us today